Sevgili 9. sınıflar tekrar beraberiz.
Hangi ünitemizde? Eski çağda inanç bilim
ve sanat ünitesinde. Bu dersin PDF'ini
videonun alttaki linkimizden yine
ulaşabilirsiniz. Mari sınıfın linkinden
arkadaşlar oraya girip tarih bölümüne
tıklayıp arkadaşlar bütün PDF'leri
indirebilirsiniz. Bu PDF'ler aslında
önümüzdeki y oluşan kitapların da
altyapısını oluşturacak arkadaşlar.
Bunla lütfen dosyalın ve siz de bunu
ücretsiz bir şekilde kullanın. Şimdi bu
sene bizim kendi kanalımızda aslında
arkadaşlar AYT, KPSS, TYT 9'lar hepsi
bir arada altyapı kuruyoruz. Yani bu
kanal aslında bu sene eee yeniden
doğuyor. Eee bu altyapı çalışması var. O
yüzden biraz yoğun geçiyor sezonumuz
arkadaşlar ama eee biraz eee videolar
haftanın azıcık gerisinde kalabiliyor
arkadaşlar ama yetiştik. Yetiştik merak
etmeyin. Yazılılarda önceden geleceğiz.
Hiç hiç tert etmeyin. 34 tane videom
kaldı. Ana kampları bitirmek üzereyim.
Daha sonra sizle daha sıkı beraber
olacağız. Sadece abone olup bildirimleri
açmayı unutmayın. Çünkü bu kanala siz de
9'da, 10'da, 11'de, 12'de tamamen hep
birlikte olacağız arkadaşlar. Siz 12'ye
geldiğinizde siz hazır bir şekilde
tarihten sınava girmiş olacaksınız
diyorum. O zaman bu dersimizde eski
çağda inanç bilim ve sanatı konuşacağız
arkadaşlar. Aslında eee kolay bir ders.
Çok zor bir ders değil. Ezber yapmayın.
Sadece mantığı kavramaya çalışın. Eee
kitaptaki sıraya göre gideceğiz. Kitapla
paralel gideceğiz arkadaşlarım. Ve
burada mantık şu olacak aslında. İnanç
sistemi devlet yönetimini, inanç sistemi
sanatı, inanç sistemi bilimi hepsi ne
yapmış? Etkilemiş. Bunları birlikte ne
yapmış olacağız? Değerlendirmiş
olacağız. Önce nereden başlıyoruz?
Mezopotamya'dan. Hazırsanız başlayalım.
Arkadaşlar şimdi arkadaşlar 2. ünitenin
4. bölümündeyiz. Bu bölümde Anadolu'ya
bakacağız. İşte şu kalemi de göstereyim.
Anadolu'ya bakacağız. Kalemi
değiştiremedim. Anadolu'ya bakacağız.
Mezopotamya'ya bakacağız. Mısır
bölgesine, Türkistan bölgesine
bakacağız. Yani burada sistem neydi?
Bunları tek tek değerlendireceğiz. Önce
neyle başlıyoruz? Eee, Mezopotamya'yile
başlıyoruz arkadaşlar. Mezopotamya
dersek Fırat ile Dicde nehide arasında
kalan bölge Mezopotamya olarak geçiyordu
ki Anadolu'yu, Mısır'ı birçok bölgeyi
etkileyen bir uygarlıktır. Eee,
medeniyetin beşiği olarak kabul edilir
arkadaşlarım. Ve burada da biz kimi
ölçüsü alacağız? Sümerleri merkezimize
alacağız ve birlikte değerlendireceğiz
arkadaşlarım. İsterseniz başlayalım.
Hatta başlamadan şuraya şöyle siz de bir
ok çıkartın. Çıktı aldıysanız arkadaşlar
notunuzla ilgili ok çıkartın ve şunu
yazın. Sümerlerde ülke patesi ya da ensi
denilen kimler tarafından yönetiliyordu?
Rahip krallar tarafından yönetiliyordu.
Bu neden yazdım biliyor musunuz
arkadaşlar? Bakın kral aynı zamanda
rahipmiş. O zaman burada inanç bilimi,
inanç sanatı, inanç yönetimi de
etkilemiş mi? Etkilemiş. Dolayısıyla
burada inanç sistemini konuşacağız
arkadaşlarım. Ama yönetimle idare ile
inancın iç içe olduğunu da aklınızdan
çıkarmayın. O zaman devam edelim. Şimdi
önce Mezopotamya'da din anlayışı ile
başlayalım arkadaşlar. Mezopotamya'da
çok tanrılı bir din inanç sistemi söz
konusu idi. O halde arkadaşlar bunu
şöyle birazcık kanunlaştırayım. Kalemi
çok ince kaldı. Çok tanrılı bir inanç
sistemi. Ezbere gerek yok demiştim.
Gerçekten de çok ezbere gerek var mı?
Yok. Politeist kavramına dikkat edin
arkadaşlar. Politeist çok tanrılı inanç
sistemlerine politeist inanç sistemleri
denir. Çok tanrı anlayış denir
arkadaşlar. Peki dersimiz devam edecek
ama genel kültür anlamında da şunu bana
cevaplar mısınız? Tarihte ilk defa tek
tanrılı dine inanan kim arkadaşlar? İlk
çağda, eski çağda var mı öyle bir şey?
Var. O da kimlerdir? İbranilerdir. İlk
defa tek tane dine inanan millettir
arkadaşlar. İbraniler. Onlar Hz. Musa'ya
inanmışlardır. Hangi din? Musevilik. Ama
İbraniler dediğimiz Yahudilerin ataları
arkadaşlar. Yahudiler yani onlar o dinin
sadece kendilerine gönderine
inanmışlardır. Dolayısıyla da bu dini
yaymak amacıyla uğraşmamışlardır. Şimdi
Mezopotamya'dayız, Sümerlerdeyiz. Çok
tanrı bir inanış var. Onlarda her şeyin
koruyucu bir tanrısı var arkadaşlar.
Dedim her şeyi ezberlemeyin. Tanrılar
insanına doğrudan müdahale ettiğine
inanmışlar tanrıların. Bakın eee
yalnızca ibadet yeri değil onlara göre
tapınaklar. Şurada tapınağı görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar. Şimdi Mezopotamya dersek
aklımız bir kere ne gelecek? Zigurat
gelecek. Ziguratı asla unutmayacaksınız.
Burada arkadaşlar ekonomik ve idari
merkezler olarak da kullanmış. Hatta
tapınakların en üst katı rasathane
olarak kullanmış. Şimdi bunları
konuşacağız zaten. Dolayısıyla gözlem
evi hangi bilim gelişecek o zaman?
Astronomi gelişecek. Bakın inanç
sistemleri neyi etkiledi? Direkt
arkadaşlarım bilimi etkiledi. O zaman
siz burada bir kere zigurat kelimesine
çok dikkat edin sevgili arkadaşlarım.
Zigurat kelimesi ne demekmiş? Zigurat
basamaklı
piramit demekmiş arkadaşlar. Şöyle içini
de sarıya boyamış olalım. Şimdi
ziguratlar, basamaklı mabetler,
basamaklı piramitler genelde üç bölümden
oluşuyor arkadaşlar. Aslında 7 kata
kadar çıkmış bunlar ama en çok üç katlı
yapılıyor. İlk katlar genel olarak
arkadaşlar erzak deposu olarak
kullanılıyor. Bakın ne deposu? Erzak
deposu. O zaman düşünsene erzakların
buraya gelmesi, burada toplanması
genelde vergiler buralarda toplanmış
arkadaşlar. O zaman bakın vergiler
burada toplanıyorsa demek ki ülke
yönetimi teokratik bir yapıya sahip. Bu
kavramı öğrendik mi arkadaşlar sizle? Bu
kavram bizim için önemli mi? Çok çok
önemli. Neye sahip diyoruz arkadaşlar?
Teokratik. Yani ülke neye göre
yönetiliyor? Dine göre. Çünkü vergiler
nereye getirmiş? Tapınağa getirmiş
arkadaşlar. İlk katlar, erzak taposu.
Orta katlar okul ve tapınak olarak
kullanmış arkadaşlar. Yazıcı okul
olarak. Şimdi Sümerler tarihte ilk defa
neyi kullanmışlardı? Yazıyı. Burada
insanlara neyi öğretmişler? Aynı zamanda
yazıyı öğretmişler ve tanrıya yakın
olmak için de yüksek yapılmış
arkadaşlar. O zaman siz sınavda yazılıda
bir yerde karşınıza çıkarsa zigurat
kavramı çıkarsa arkadaşlar ne
yapıyorsunuz? Zigurat kavramının
sümelere ait olduğunu ve tapınakla
ilgili olduğunu aklınızdan
çıkarmıyorsunuz. Peki ziguratlar niçin
kullanmış arkadaşlar? Burayı da lütfen
dikkat edelim. Bakın tapınak olarak
kullanılmış. Tahıl ambarı olarak
kullanmış. Soğuk hava deposu olarak
kullanılmış. Eğitim merkezi, gözlem evi.
Gözlem evi dediğimiz şey nedir
arkadaşlarım? Rasathane. Rasathane. Yani
hangi bilimle uğraşmışlar? Direkt
söylediğimiz şey astronomi. Bunu bilinde
zaten vurgulayacağız. Kütüphane olarak
kullanılmış. Arşiv, yazıcı okulu olarak
da ne yapılmış? Kullanmış diyebiliriz. O
zaman inanç sistemleri çok tanrılı. Her
şehrin bir koruyucusu var arkadaşlarım.
Her şehrin bir koruyucu tanrısı var.
Eee, zigorat denilen tapınaklar
yapmışlar şehir merkezlerinde. Bunlar
aklınızda kalsın arkadaşlar. Krallar
tanrı adına ülkeyi yönettiğini
düşünmüşler, kabul etmişler. Din ile
devlet işleri içe. O zaman burada şu
kavramı YKS için aslan unutmayın
arkadaşlarım. Teokrasi nedir? Teokrasi
devletin dine göre yönetilmesi.
Arkadaşlarım Asurlarla ilgili bir
kitapta bazı bilgiler var sevgili
arkadaşlarım. Asurlarda da inanç sistemi
içerisinde gene aynı eee çok tanrı bir
inanç sistemi var. Saray ve tapınaklar
ön planda. Lamassu heykellerine dikkat
edin arkadaşlar. Lamassu zaten Lamassu
Lamassu içerisinde ne var? Asurun
harfleri var mı? Asurun harfleri var.
Neye de geçiyor arkadaşlar? Bakın lamaya
da benziyor zaten. Lama. Gördünüz mü?
Laya benzetin ama lama sular arkadaşlar
bakın a sularda insan boğa ve aslan
başlığı heykel veren isimmiş arkadaşlar.
O zaman sorarlarsa lamasu nerede? İçinde
harflere bak. Lamassu asurlarda. Ne?
Lamasu dediğimiz şey lamaya benzeyen
değil mi? İnsan, boğa ve aslan başlı
heykellere verilen isim. Arkadaşlar
bakın inanç sistemi ile alakalı bu
lamazsular. Askeri, dini ve günlük
yaşamın yansıtıldığı heykellerde kralın
gücünü temsil etmiş arkadaşlar ve
düşmana korku salmış. Bu heykellerin
kendilerini koruduğu kötü ruhlardan
koruma amacı taşımış arkadaşlar.
Düşünsene sarayların dışında bu
lamassular var. Lamassu Mezopotamı bilim
dersek arkadaşlar gene bilim ihtiyaca
bağlı olarak ortaya çıkmış gelişmiş.
Burada eee astronomi, matematik tıp
alanında önemli çalışmalar yapılmış mı
arkadaşlarım? Yapılmış. Dört işlemi
kullanmışlar. Bölme çarpma cetvellerini
kullanmışlar. Yüzey hacim ölçmeyi
gerçekleştirmişler. Daireyi 360 dereceye
bölmüşler. 2 3 bilinmeyen denklemleri
çözmüşler. Tıp alan çalışmalar var
arkadaşlarım. Kil tabletler üzerine çivi
yazıyla bu belgeleri de bilgileri
kaydetmişler. O zaman arkadaşlar bakın
yazının kullanılması o çağdaki bilgi
birikiminin günümüze aktarılmasına katkı
sağlamış mıdır arkadaşlar? Sağlamıştır.
Şunu çok fazla aklınızda tutabilirsiniz
arkadaşlarım. Güneş ve ay tutulmasını
ilk kez hesaplayan Sümerlerdir. Ay yıl
esasına dayanan bir takvim yapmışlardır.
Takvim yaptılarsa hangi bilim
gelişmiştir arkadaşlar? Astronomi.
Arkadaşlar tarihte ilginç olaylar da
var. Bak bu Sümerler güneş ve ayı
tutması hesaplarken Halitç savaşı ile
bir savaş var. Taraflar o savaş sırası
güneş tutuluyor. Allah bize Allah de
onlar için Tanrı diyelim artık. Tanrı
bize kızdı diye arkadaşlar ne
yapıyorlar? Savaşı bırakıyorlar. Öpü
koklaşım. Hadi bakalım görüşürüz deyip
savaş meydanına ayrılıyorlar. Aslında
cehalet de bir tartı var. Burada ise
güneş ve ay tutması hesaplanmış. Kil
tabletler üzerine arkadaşlar birçok
kanunları, ediye metinleri yazmışlar.
Asurlarda Nenova'da bir kütüphane kurmuş
arkadaşlar. O zaman Asurular dersek
Ninoma'da bir kütüphane. Bunu örnek
olarak her zaman verebilirsiniz. Bilime,
eğitime önem vermesi konusunda. Sümerler
çok çok önde zaten arkadaşlarım. Bakın
bölme çarpma cetvelleri dedik. Yüzey
hacim ölçme, dairenin 360 derece
bölünmesi, 23 bilinmeyeli denklemler.
Anlaştık mı? Peki sanata bakarsak
arkadaşlarım, sanat dersek dini ve asker
amaçlı sanat eserleri ortaya çıkmış
aslında arkadaşlar. Yani daha do sanatı
yansıan sanatı yansıtan eserler ortaya
koymuşlar. Burada arkadaşlar şunu asla
aklınızdan çıkarmayın. Yıldızlı
bilgidir. Süanilerde birçok eser
yapılmasına rağmen en önemlisi zigurat
denilen tapınaklar. Sümer sanatının en
önemli izlerini taşır arkadaşlarım ama
günümüze çok fazla kalmamıştır. Neden?
Çünkü Mezopotamya'da taş az. Daha çok
kerpişten yapılmıştır arkadaşlarım. Bu
da çok fazla günümüze gelmemiştir.
Kerpişten yapılması arkadaşlar eserlerin
günümüze gelmesine engel olmuştur
diyebiliriz. O zaman buraya ne
yapıyoruz? Yıldızımızı koyuyoruz. Saray
duvarları kabartmalarla süslenmiştir
arkadaşlar. Şu lamassu heykellerini
artık yazılı sorarsa örnek olarak
verebilirsiniz. Asurlar da lamassulamaya
benziyor. Bakın insan başlı heykeller.
Eee başka arkadaşlarım kabartmalara çok
fazla önem verilmiş. Kralların gücünü ve
tanrıları bağlılığı simgelemiş
arkadaşlar. Heykeller güç, korkutuculuk
ve korkutuculuk ve ihtişam ön planda. E
insan başlığı kanatlı boğa ve aslan
heykelleri. Arkadaşlar a sorularda
söyledik zaten önemli. Başka
arkadaşlarım daha çok estetik ön planda
değil güç gösterisi ön planda. Bunlar da
sanatla ilgili. Ezber yapmayın. Sadece
mantığını anlamaya çalışın.
Yorulabilecek birkaç kelime, cümle
katmaya kapmaya çalışın yazılılarda
arkadaşlarım. Peki önemli kavramlar var.
Kerpiç, Mezopotamya varisinin temel
malzemesi dayanıksız olduğu için eserler
günümüze kadar gelmemiş. Zigurat neydi?
Basamaklı piramit. Kimde? Sümerlerde.
Lamasu saray kapılarını koruyan kanatlı
insan başlı heykeller. Kabartma rölyeft
diye geçer arkadaşlarım. Duvarlara
yapılan taş süsleme sanatı kabartma
zaten isminden de belli mi? Belli.
Bunlar kenarlarıyla yeterli olacaktır
arkadaşlarım. Mısır. Mısır apari bir
uygarlık. Hala günümüzde gerçekten de
değil mi arkadaşlar? Şaşırtıcı bir
uygarlık. Nin nehrinin armağanıdır diyor
Herodot. Bakın arkadaşlar size Mısır'la
ilgili bir soru çıkarsa siz direkt şu
cümleye başlayın. Zaten delik puanı
alırsınız. Herodot tarihçi tarihin
babası biliyorsunuz arkadaşlar. O da
Bodrumlu [kahkaha] kendi ufay
çıkaracağım dermişim. Herodot arkadaşlar
tarihçi tarihin babası. Diyor ki Mısır
Nin Nehrinin armağanıdır. Demek ki ne
demek bu arkadaşlar? Mısır Nin Nehri
etrafında gelişmiştir. Buraya ne yapın?
Dikkat edin. Mısır'ın etrafı çöller ve
denizlerle kaplı arkadaşlar. Kendine
özgü bir uygarlık olmasına yol açı. Bak
eğer siz Mısır'la ilgili bir yerde
konuşacaksanız, bir yerde yorum
yazacaksınız, bunu asla
unutmayacaksınız. Diyeceksiniz ki
kardeşim bir Mısır'da çöller var. Etrafı
denizlerle kaplı. Dolayısıyla Mısır
uygarlığı diğer uygarlıklarla etkileş
içerisine girmemiş. Şöyle Anadolu olsun
arkadaşlar. Şöyle Akdeniz olsun. Şurası
Kızıldeniz olsun. Aha Mısır burada. Bak
zaten burası deniz. E burası çöller
kaplı. O zaman diğer uygarlıklar
etkileşim olursa kendine özgü bir
uygarlık. Bak o zaman mısır uygarlığının
daha çok kendine özgü bir uygarlık
olduğunu vurgulayabilirsiniz.
Burası bizim için arkadaşlar önemli mi?
Önemli. Şöyle içini de sarıya boyamış
olalım. Kendine özgü bir uygarlık.
Mısır'da arkadaşlar inanca bakarsak
inanç sistemine çok enteresan. Burada
direkt neyi görmek lazım? Hemen aklınıza
ilk söyleyeceğiniz kelime tabii ki ne
olur? Firavunlar olur. Firavunlar.
Firavun arkadaşlar nedir? kendisini
tanrı olarak kabul ettiren krallardır.
Çok enteresan değil mi? Bakın
Anadolu'da, Mezopotamya'da
işte ne bileyim Türkistan'da, Orta
Asya'da bu şekilde kendini tanrılaştıran
krallar arasmak çok zor. Ender arada
birkaç örnek var ama arkadaşlar Mısır'da
ise firavunlar kendilerini tanrı olarak
kabul etmiş. İnsanoğlu buna inanmış mı?
İnanmış. Tabii neile alakalı? Güçle
alakalı arkadaşlar. Bu nasıl oluyor
biliyor musunuz? Nil nehriyle. Gene bak
Mısır'a hayat veren nehri. Nilin
akışının düzenli olması kralların,
firavunların buraya koydukları
kayıklarla, gemilerle Mısır'ı çok kolay
kontrol altında alması, baskı kurmasına
yol açmıştır arkadaşlar. Ve krallarını
tanrı olarak görmüşler. Tanrı olarak
tapmışlar. O zaman arkadaşlar otorite,
merkezi otorite güçlü. Gene politeist
bir inanış var arkadaşlar. Çok tanrılı
bir inanış var. Firavunlar ilah olarak,
tanrı olarak görmüş. Ölümden sonra yaşam
inancı var, ahiret inancı var
arkadaşlar. Şimdi burada sorular çıkarsa
mezar içine eşya falan konuluyorsa hep
neyi gösterir bize? Ayriet inancın
varlığı gösterir. Onlar şöyle bir inanış
var. Onlarda ruhun ve bedenin ölümden
sonra varlığını sürdürüğüne dair bir
inanç var. Mesela bizde de ahiret inancı
var değil mi? Öldürükten sonra
yaşayacağız. Cennete ya da cehenneme
gideceğiz diye inanışımız var. Ama beden
toprak olacak ruh öbür dünyada yaşayacak
mantığı var bizde. Mısır'da ise beden ve
ruh ikisi de yaşayacak. Yani ruh
bedenden çıkacak ama tekrar o bedene
geri dönecek öbür dünyada. O yüzden de
bakın mumyalama ortaya çıkmış. İnanç
sistemi neyi getirmiş arkadaşlarım?
Mumyalamayı. Mantık ezbere hiç gerek yok
bu derste. Bu ders öyle sizin
düşündüğünüz gibi arkadaşlar ezber bir
tarih dersi değil. Mumyalamayı
beraberine getirmiş arkadaşlarım. Ve
firavunlar için ise piramitler
yapmışlar. Piramit mezarlar ki hala
sırları çözmüş değil. Ve enteresan
özellikleri var. Mesela neden dünyada
yapılan bütün piramitler belli bir enlem
üzerine inşa edilmiş? Mesela genelde
bunu bazı kaynaklar uzaylılara bağlıyor
ya arkadaşlar. Ne düşünüyorsunuz sizce?
Uzaylı var mı arkadaşlar? Yani
piramitleri uzaylılar mı yaptı? Mesela
kimise diyor ki piramitlerin tepesindeki
o şimdi artık yok ama üzerindeki o
şeyler metaller falan uzaylara bir
sinyal göndermek içindir falan.
Bilemiyorum ben evrende yalnız
olmadığımı düşünüyorum arkadaşlar. Yani
evren çok büyük ya. Çok çok büyük.
Sadece insanlardan oluşmuyor evren. Yani
o kadar değerli değiliz. Küçük bir
parçayız. Noktayız hatta. Değil mi? Ama
uzaylılar belki de biz uzaylıyız.
Ötekilere zulmediyoruz. Bilmiyorum ki
arkadaşlar. Uzaylı zaten de bu konuda
karışık kafam. Siz ne düşünüyorsunuz?
Merak ediyorum. Tapınaklarda her gün
ayinler düzenlemişler. Törenleri kral
veya rahipler yönetmiş arkadaşlar.
Anlaş. O zaman Mısır dersek tanrı kral
anlayışına dikkat edin. Ha Sümerlerde ne
dedim? Patesi ensi. Orada rahip kral
anlayışı var. Yani arkadaşlar Sümerlerde
krallar tanrı olarak görünmemiş. Rahip
kral olarak görmüş. İkisine de teoretik
teokratik yönetim anlayışı var. Peki
neler ortaya çıktı Mısır'da arkadaşlar?
Baktığımız zaman bir kere mumyalama
ortaya çıktı değil mi? Mumyacılık
gelişti. E mumyalama varsa arkadaşlar
eee tıp, eczacılık, anatomi gibi
bilimler gelecek. Neden biliyor musunuz?
Çünkü mumyalamak için insan bedenini
işte göbeğin altından ne yapacaksın?
Keseceksin. İç organları çıkartacaksın.
Dolayısıyla bunu ilaçlayacaksın. Bak
tıp, eczacılık, anatomi, anatom insan
bedeninin organların incelemesi ya
arkadaşlar birçok hastalığın sebebi ve
tedavisini bulmuşlar organları
inceledikleri için arkadaşlarım cerrahi
ve tedavi yöntemlerini yazılı hale
getirmişler. Papirüsler yazmışlar.
Nillerin taşması ve çekilmesi tarıma
zarar vermiş.
Bu durum arkadaşlar nehri taşma ve
çekilme zamanı hesaplanmasının
gerekliğini ortaya çıkarmış. Bu da
arkadaşlar gene bak burada astronomi,
geometri, matematik bilimlerin yani
demek ki inanç sistemi neye itki etti
arkadaşlar? Bilime. Farkındaysanız
mumyalama işi tıbbın eczacılığın
anatominin gelişmesine katkı sağladı.
Birçok hastalığın sevinin ortaya
çıkmasına, tedavinin ortaya çıkmasına
yol açtı arkadaşlar. Nin nehirin taşması
ve çekilmesi ise geometri ast şey
astronomi çünkü güneşe göre
ayarlayacaklar ya. Taşma zamanı, çekilme
zamanı. Bunu hesaplayacaklar. Matematik,
tapıkada su. Tapıkada su ne alaka? Nehri
çekilince arazi sınları ortaya çıkacak.
Ya taştığı zaman araziler kaybolacak.
Çekilince kimin nerede arazisi var?
Hangi sınırı nereden geçiyor? Bunlar
hesaplanması. O zaman burada arkadaşlar
iki unsura dikkat edin. Mısır'da bilimin
gelişmesinde iki unsur var. Kalemimi
alayım şöyle arkadaşlarım. Bir tanesi
mumyalama. Bak mumyalama inanç sistemi.
Mumyalamadan kaynaklı bir etki var.
Bilimin gelişmesi var. Ötekisi ise
arkadaşlar Nil Nehrin taşması ve
çekilmesinden kaynaklı Mısır'da bilimin
gelişmesi var. Burada arkadaşlar bir
tanesi ekonomi temeli, bir tanesi din
temelli bilimin gelişmesinde. O halde
dikkat ediyorsunuz mumyacılığın, tıbbın,
eczacılığın, anatominin gelişmesi,
anatomi gelişmesinde inanış sistemi
yatar arkadaşlarım. Astronomi, geometri,
matematik, tapıkada su takvimin
gelişmesinde ise ne yatar? Nin taşıması,
çekilmesi ekonomik nedenler yatar
arkadaşlar. Anlaştık mı? O zaman burada
neye dikkat ediyorsunuz? Güneş yıl esas
takmasında nin taşımasının çekilmesi,
tarımın düzenli hale getirmesi. Protez,
protez örneklerine rastlamış. Protez
hani bacak protezi oluyor ya, kol
protezi. O tarz protezlere rastlanmış.
Mısır'da tıbbın gelişini gösterir.
Mısırlar hiyerif denilen resim yazısını
kullandır arkadaşlar. Zaten ben şöyle
kodlarım bunu hep. Resim dersek aklınıza
kim gelecek? M harfi mısırlılar. resim
yazısı mısırlar papirs denilen bitki
liflerine oluşan kağıtlara yazdılar
arkadaşlar mısırların papirs ve fırça
kullanması onlarda arkadaşlar e daha
doğrusu tarihteşeli bir şey sağladı
yazının taşınabilirliğini Sümerlerde kil
tabletleri yazılıyordu arkadaşlar
çamurdan tabletler yapılıyordu çiviyle
sert uçlu bir çubukla oraya yazılıyordu
ama Mısır'da işte içti papürüstleri
arkadaşlar yazılmaya başlandı hatta
ileride göreceğiz Bergama Krallığında da
parşömen denilen kağıtlara yazılıyor bir
tahta çakılıyor çiviyle orada da
kitaplar oluşuyor arkadaşlar. Aslında bu
papürüs ve fırçanın kullanımı yazının
taşınabilirliğini
yanında taşıyabilirsin. Ne yapıyor?
Sağlıyor. Sanat dersek gene arkadaşlar
inanç temelli değil mi? Eee bakın
piramit zaten en güzel örneği, Mısır
sanatının en önemli örneği anıt
mezarları arkadaşlar. Piramitler,
tapınaklar, mezar anıtları. Yani
firavunların yüceltilmesine ve dini
inançların gösterilmesiyle alakalı daha
çok sanatlar yapılmış arkadaşlar.
Heykeller, kabartmalar, resimler daha
çok günlük yaşamı yansımış arkadaşlarım.
Binlerce yıllık freskler var. Freskin ne
olduğunu bilin arkadaşlar. Fresk nedir?
Fresk çıkarsa sorularda duvar resmi
olduğunu bilin arkadaşlar. Duvarın yaş
bir alçı ile kaplanıp üzerine yaş alçıya
boyanın emdirmesi yapılan resimlerdir.
Fresler arkadaşlarım. Peki geldik
Anadolu'ya. Şimdi Anadolu'da inanç
dersek arkadaşlar şimdi burada da
Hititleri merkeze alacağız. Kitap bir de
Urartullar almış Anadolu içerisinde
arkadaşlarım çok tanrılı. Politeist.
Hatta bak burada da bunu asla unutma.
Çok tanrı. Hepsi çoktan ama Hititler
abartmışlar. Hititler abartmışlar. Hitit
ülkesi için sevgili arkadaşlarım Hitit
ülkesi için şöyle boyayayım burasını.
Hitit ülkesi için 1000 tanrı ili
diyorlar. 1000 tanrı ili ne demek? 1000
tanrı ili bunun nedeni ne biliyor
musunuz arkadaşlar? Hititler şurada
yazıyor. Bakın dikkat kısmında
açıklamışım zaten. Bir ele
geçirdiklerinde ele geçirdiği bölgenin
tanrısı kendilerine kızmasın diye o
bölgenin tanrılarını da kendi tanrıları
yapıyorlar.
Tanrı idi. Nereye ele geçirdin? A tanrı
kızması. Biz sana tapıyoruz. Bir yere
ele geçti. A sana tapıyoruz. Bir sürü
tanrılı olmuş. 1000 tanrı eli olarak
geçiyor. İnançları gereği arkadaşlar
Hititler tanrılarına hesap vermek için
her yıl analilen yıllıklar yazıyorlar
arkadaşlar. Bakın bu da çok önemli.
Bakın niçin? Tanrına hesap vermek için.
Anallara dikkat edin. Hititlerde
zaferleri de yazıyorlar yenilgeler de.
Çünkü tanrıya hesap vermek için yıllık
bizim günlüğün daha geniş hali düşün. Ve
bu da tarafsız tarih yazının başlangıcı.
Bakın ne oldu? İnanç neyi etkiledi?
Bilimi. Yani sizde bu konuyla ilgili
açıklama yaparken arkadaşlar bu ilişkiyi
açıklamaya çalışıyor. Tamam mı? İnancın
bilim etkilemesi, ekonominin bilinci
etkil bilim etkilemesi, öz bilinç
diyorum bilim etkilemesi artı sanatı
etkilemesini açıklayacaksınız. Zigurat
örnek verirsiniz. Piramitlere örnek
verirsiniz aslında ders dediğim
gerçekten ezber bir ders değil.
Hititlerde gene astronomi gelişmiş, tıp
gelişmiş arkadaşlar. Birçok hastalın
teşvif ve tedavisine büyük önem
vermişler. Hayvan anatomisi gelişmiş.
Neden biliyor musunuz? Adamlar dini
törenlerde ritüeller gerçekleşmişler.
Kurban kesme. E bizde de var kurban
kesme. E hiç kurban kesmine katıldınız
mı? Ben mesela kurban kesimde yardım
ediyorum. Ben kesemem de yardımcıyım
ben. Su döküveriyorum. İşte bir şey
temizlenecekse onlara destek oluyor
falan arkadaşlar kurban kesme sırasında.
Ama ne yapıyorsun? Organları
çıkartıyorsun. Tek tek onları
görüyorsun. Bakın arkadaşlar hayvan
anatomisine gelişmiş. Neden dolayı? Dini
törenlerden dolayı. Oradaki ritüellerden
dolayı.
Güzel bir TYT sorusu çıkar buradan.
Sanata bakalım arkadaşlar. Gene Hit
sanatı Anadolu, Mezopotamya, Mısır
sanatına etkilenmişti arkadaşlar. Burada
da bak bunu ön plana çıkart. Tamam mı?
Eğer Anadolu'dan bir örnek sayacaksak
arkadaşlar titlerde İvriz ve yazılı kaya
kabartmalarını kabartmadır. Yazılı kaya
der ama yazılıdan bahsetmez arkadaşlar.
Orası 12 tane tanrı tasviri vardır
arkadaşlar. Orada şurada aldım ben onu.
Bak şu yazılı kabartmaları görüyorsunuz
zaten arkadaşlarım. Eee Hitit sanatının
en önemli örneklerindendir. Lütfen bunu
da anlatabilirsiniz. Yazılıy
apartmanlarının 12 tane yeraltı
tanrısını tasvir ettiğini. Bak bunların
hepsi neymiş? Yeraltı tanrısıymış
arkadaşlar. Onlara göre Hititler hem
çivi yazsını hem de hırfi kullanmıştır
arkadaşlar. Ben bunu şöyle öğreteceğim
size. YKS'de
hu yapacağız. Hu hu var ya hu derviş
selamı. Hu veyahut da maçlarda hu diye
ses geliyor ya tribünlerde. Hu hu hu hu
diye arkadaşlar. Hititler ve Urartular.
Anadolu'da iki tane uygarlık. Hititler
urartular. Bunlar ne yazısı
kullanmışlardır? Çivi ve resim yazısı
kullanmışlardır. Harf yazısı
kullanmamışlardır. Diğerler harf yazısı
kullanmışlar arkadaşlar. Hiçitler harf
yazısı yok. Ya çivi yazısı kullanmışlar
ya da resim hiyeroklip yazısı. Bir de
kim var arkadaşlar? Urartular. Başta ne
çıktı? Ho. Bunu unutma. Bu notunu da al.
Bize lazım olacak mı? Yerlerde lazım
olacak arkadaşlar. Urartularda gene
Anadolu'da arkadaşlarım Urartularda da
Haldi'yi lütfen örnek alın. Haldi savaş
tanrısıdır kendisi. Haldi gidelim. haldi
savaşa gidiyorlar böyle biz nasıl
gidiyoruz? Allah Allah diye gidiyoruz.
Onlar halde halde halde diye gidiyorlar.
Savaş tanrısı. Bakın inanç sistemleri
onların nasıl bir uygarlık olduğunu
gösterdi savaşçı zaten Doğu Anadolu'da
kurulmuşlar. Van bölgesinde e sert
iklim, sert şartlar arkadaşlar. Savaş ve
uygarlık merdivenlerde inilen mezarlar
yapmışlar. Kaya mezarları çok meşhur
arkadaşlarım. Burada da Şamran kanalını
merkeze al bak sanat illa konuşulacaksa
arkadaşlar burada da şamran kanalı
aslında bilime de örnek verebilirsiniz.
günümüzde hala kullanılıyor. Van'da
arkadaşlar belli Menoa kanalı da geçiyor
arkadaşlarım. Kral Menua yapıldığı için
günümüzde hala kullanan kanaldır. Bu da
neyle ilgili? İnanç değil arkadaşlar. Bu
sefer ekonomi bak sanatın gelişmesinde
özür dilerim bilimin gelişmesinde çünkü
suyun tahesi il çalışmadır. Sgulama
kanalı değil mi arkadaşlarım? O zaman
menuan kanalında Urartulardan aklınıza
çıkar. İnanç kısmında da hal diye dikkat
edin. O önemli. Avrupa'da dersek
arkadaşlar Yunan uygarlığı karşımıza
çıkar. O da Mezopotamya ve Mısır
uygarlığı etkilenmiştir arkadaşlarım.
Ama Yunanlılar tanrılarını insan gibi
düşünmüşlerdir. Onlara göre tanrılar
yer, içer, üzülür, sevilir işte sevilir,
mutlu olur, kızar. Tanrının kızmaması
için mutlu olması lazım. Burada da
olympostaa dikkat edeceksiniz
arkadaşlar. Onlar olymosanı tanrıların
evi olarak görmüş arkadaşlar. Şehirlerde
de eee tapınakları tanrının evi olarak
görmüşler. Olimposan bütün Tanrı
yaşadığı ev. Öyle düşünün yani. Ve
burada yarışmalar düzenlemişler. Şiir,
müzik, eğlence, spor, şentleri
düzenlemişler. Tanrılarını eğlendirmek
için. Ve bu da günümüz olimpiyatlarının
temelini oluşturuyor arkadaşlar. Hatta
bir bilgi daha vereyim ben size. Bu
normalde Yunan uygarlığında polis
denilen şehir devletleri vardır. Orada
ne yoktur? Biz bunu konuştuk hangisinde
değil mi arkadaşlar? Siyasi birlik
yoktur. Ama Olimposanında yapılan bu
dini törenler ise Yunan uygarlığında
neyi sağlamıştır? Siyasi birliğin
sağlanmasını şey özür dilerim siyasi
bilgi sağlayamaz. kültürel birliğin
sağlamasını sağlamıştır.
Cümle düşük oldu. Kültürel birliğin
oluşmasına yol açmıştır. Arkadaşlar
Yunanlılar bilim çok gelişmiş
arkadaşlarım. Matematik ve astronomi çok
ileri gitmişler. Güneş takvini
geliştirmişler. Fenik alfabesini
geliştirmişler. Hafkasını
geliştirmişler. Eee, polis denen
şehirleri var ya Yunanlılarda
arkadaşlar. Dolayısıyla siyasi baskı
yok. Özgür düşünce ortamı var. Para da
var arkadaşlarım. Burada da şu adamları
unutmayacaksınız arkadaşlar. Bunu not
alırsınız, söylersiniz. Herodot, Sokrat,
Platon, Aristo gibi isimler burada ön
plana çıkmış. Özgür düşünce ortamı
olduğu için birçok bilim insanı gelişmiş
arkadaşlar. Sanat olarak da mimari çok
ileri gitmişler. Tiyatrolar, agoralar,
hazine binaları, stadyumlar inşa
etmişler arkadaşlarım. Doğur, iyon ve
korint tarzı sütunları kullanmışlar
diyebiliriz.
Orta Asya'ya gelirsek, Türkistan'a
gelirsek biziz yani arkadaşlar değil mi?
Orada da, orada da tabii ki de neyi
örnek alacağız? Her zaman söyleyeceğimiz
kelime cümlemiz ne olacak? Gök tanrı
inancı. Eee, eski Türk inancı. Gök Tanrı
inancı etrafında eee şekillenmiş. Gök
Tanrı tek bir tanrı varına inanmışlar.
Şamanizm atalar kültü tabiat kültüne
inanmışlar arkadaşlar. Ben hep derslerde
söylüyorum. Atalar kültü. Bak kült
inanış demek. İnanış. Ama ben
ortaokuldayken falan öğretmenim tahtaya
atalar kültü yazdığında bayan bir
öğretmenim vardı. Ben bunu defterime
kültürü diye düzenlerdim. Düzelterek
yazardım. Öğretmenimi de söylemezdim
kırılmasın diye. Yanlış biliyor
sanıyordumu. [kahkaha] Mersin kültmüş,
kültür değilmiş. Yıllar sonra
öğrendiydim bunu. Kült inanış demek
arkadaşlar. Atalar kültü diyoruz ya.
Ölen ataların ruhlarının bizi koruduğuna
inanıyor eski Türkler. Hayatta kalanları
koruduğuna inanıyor arkadaşlar. Tabiat
kültü de doğadaki unsurların kutsal
sayılması. Bunu açıklarsınız. Gök tanrı
inancı, atalar kültü var, doğa kültü
var. Bir de sevgili arkadaşlarım
mezarlara çok öne veriyor Türkler.
Mezarlar yağma alanında bunu savaş
nedeni bile saymışlar. Burada bir de
arkadaşlar hem sanat temin anış mesela
en güzel örneği şu yanda gördüünüz. Bal
heykelleri. Bal. Bu bir heykel
arkadaşlar ama göçebe yaşamında
dikilmiş. Mezar başlarına dikilmiş ve
öldürülen düşman sayısı kadar öbür
dünyada bize hizmet edece yani onlara
bize biz varacağız elimizde ayet TYT
kitabımızda 9 kitabımızda Allah
göstermesin vardık öbür dünyaya. Ne bir
kahramanlık gösterdin ne bir balın var.
Adam bir tanesi gidiyor önden bir sürü
arkada hizmetçisi var. Soruyorsun bu ne
diyorsun? Bak öndeki metan arkadaki
baları falan. Eski Türkler de buna
inanmışlar. öldürülen düşman sayısı
kadar mezar başına dikiliyor. Öbür
dünyada arkadaşlar, eee, hizmet
edeceğini inanılıyor. O zaman balbal
heykel sanatının değil mi? Türklerde
gelişmesini gösteren unsur arkadaşlarım.
Balballar. Aynı zamanda balara
baktığımız zaman kahramanlar Türklerin
önemi verdiğini gösterir. Arkadaşlarım
Türklerde mezarlara kurgan denilir
arkadaşlar. Kurgan içine eşya gönüle
mezarlardır. O zaman kurgan ahiret
inancını gösterir. Tamı cehennemdir.
Sevmedim birisi söyledi. Oh tam
cehennemlik var. O var ya tam
cehennemlik. Tam cennet uçma demek.
Sevdiğim biri vefat etti. Uçmağa gitti.
Cennete gitti. Uçup dur oralarda.
Mezarlara eşya konulması kurgan tamam mı
uçma bunlar arkadaşlar hep ne? Ahiret
inancını gösteriyor. Türklerde nadir de
olsa mumyalanma görmüş arkadaşlar.
Atalar kültü, aile inancının göstergesi.
Ölen atan ruhunun bizi koruduğuna
yaşıyor demek ki. Yaşaması bizi nasıl
koruyacak? Ona inanmışız yani
arkadaşlar. Değil mi? Türk İslam'da
bilim dersek arkadaşlar eğitim var.
Yaygın eğitim, örgün eğitimi var
arkadaşlar. Örgün eğitim dersek aslında
okullarda yapılan eğitimdir arkadaşlar.
Bu da örgün eğitim nerede başlar?
Uygurlarda. Çünkü okul olması için
yerleşik yaşam lazım, bina lazım.
Uygurlarda arkadaşlar 23 tane okulun
varlığından bahsediliyor. Tıt 120
koduyla Uygurlarda bir tıp kitabına
rastlamış arkadaşlar. Tıp kitabı var.
Bakın. eee körlük, göze pusinmesi, baş
ağrısı, kulak hastalıkları, kalp
hastalığı gibi birçok hastalıkların
tedavisini yapmışlar. Türklerde,
göktürklerde pulluk ve kürek gibi
aletlere rastlanması, sert çelik ve
yumuşak çelikten bahsedilmesi
kaynaklarda demir işlemcinin olması
bilimde işlediğini, bilimin geliştiğini
gösterir. Kengeş, Keneşi ya da Tayanç
denilen bilim danışmanları varmış
Türklerde arkadaşlar. Ve burada da siz
tabii ki şunu örnek verebilirsiniz
arkadaşlarım. 12 hayvanın Türk takvimini
örnek verebilirsiniz. Neden
verebilirsiniz? Çünkü bu da takvim
yapılırsa yapıldıysa astronomi ile
uğraşıldığını gösterir. Bak tıp kitabı
olduğunu söyledik. Tıp 120. Örgün eğitim
olduğunu söyledik arkadaşlar. Serçeri
işlediğini söyledik. Bunlar da
arkadaşlar bilimin geliştiğini gösterir
mi? Gösterir. Sanata bakarsak arkadaşlar
buradaki en ön vereceğiniz örnek ne
olacaktır? Tabii ki de hayvan üstü
olacaktır. E konar göçer yaşam. Neyle
uğraşıyoruz? Hayvancılıkla. Bütün
süslemelerde hayvan motiflerimiz var.
Biz buna hayvan üstü bu diyoruz
arkadaşlar. Genelde süslemelerde hep bu
kullanılmış arkadaşlarım. Genelde
taşınabilir sanat eserlerimiz var. Niye?
Çünkü göçebe yaşamdayız. Uygurlarla
beraber yerleşik yaşam başlayacak
arkadaşlarım. Halı dokumucu da çok ileri
gitmiş. Zaten dünyanın ilk düğümlsı bize
pazır kalısı diye geçer arkadaşlar. Biz
de pazır kurganda bulunduğu için pazır
kalısı diye geçiyor arkadaşlar. Bir de
altın elbiseli adam zırhı var. O da gene
kime ait arkadaşlar? Türklere ait
altından bakın zırh yapmışlar. Mezarda
bulunmuş. Neyi gösterir? Maden
iştirmecinde. Sanatta da etkilendiğini
dinin sanatı etkilettiğini söyleyebilir
miyiz arkadaşlar? söyleyebiliriz.
Başka arkadaşlarım eee ya daha çok şey
var ama o çok mesela Uygurlarda Budizmin
etkisiyle 30 çiçeği çok işlemiş motif
olarak şeylerde, süslerde. Türk çadırı
sanatın gene en önemli örneklerinden
arkadaşlarım. Koşum takımları, at
arabaları değil mi? Çadır, Türk çadırı
aynı zamanda kubbeli yapıın
örneği aslında arkadaşlar. Hani sonradan
yapılan şeylerin eee Selçuklu tarafından
yapılan mezarlara Türk çadır örnek
olmuşlar. Öyle diyeyim. Yani şekil
olarak minyatür, çini ve fresk de gene
bu tür sanatlarda görmüş arkadaşlarım.
Minyatür dersek arkadaşlar, minyatürü
siz şöyle öğrenin. Minyatür kale deriz
ya mesela minyatürü şu kalemimi
değiştireyim pardon değiştiremedim. Ne
olsun? Kırmızı olsun belli olsun.
Minyatür dersek arkadaşlar el yazması
kitaplardaki resimdir. Bak ne resmi?
Kitap resmidir arkadaşlar. Minyatürler.
Çini seramikler üzerine yapılan
süslemelerdir arkadaşlarım. Fres de
duvar resimli olarak karşımıza çıkıyor.
O zaman ne yaptık arkadaşlar? Buraları
halletmiş olduk. Burası arkadaşlar bu
konu çok ezberlik bir konu değil.
Mantığını kavrama konusu. Notunuzu
indirin. Şöyle bir tarayın, okuyun.
Merak ederseniz sanat sistemlere falan
bakabilirsiniz. Güzel de olur aslında
arkadaşlar. O zaman bu konuyu hallettik.
Diğer ünitemizde görüşmek üzere diyelim.
[müzik]